most cringe-worthy thing i've ever seen
in my entire life that's not a touch
millennial this is
oh i am scarlett a 30 year old college
student currently living in the dorms
alongside gen z kids they keep saying
dumb stuff to me so i'm going to keep
posting these
the following emojis don't mean what i
thought they mean
this is apparently very passive
aggressive these days so if you get this
be insulted immediately this for some
godforsaken reason means either innocent
or horny
[Applause]
why
this one still means silly but more in a
tongue-in-cheek way they call it silly
goofy mood
this one means ashamed or shy but also
sometimes horny
this one means [ __ ] my life
this is i'm stressed but it's fine
this one means and i quote i'm killing
myself tonight
this one means i'm listening
sounds good to me
or
this means titties now
probably doesn't mean my titties but
they mean titties
i also found out that you should not be
using any emoji with teeth in it because
it's cringe and you should not be using
the mind blown emoji because that's also
cringe
you probably know this one but this
means i died laughing that was so funny
that i died this one means i'm lying or
i'm not lying it could mean both or
either i still haven't figured it out
you would think this is crying but no
now it means i'm super embarrassed this
good old cowboy now means
this situation everything in the
situation everyone in it i don't know if
it's commonly used but i like this a lot
it's called standing man and it means
you feel very awkward in a situation let
me give you an example
standing man
this now means i'm leaving or you know
when in doubt dance out
this this this means nothing this was i
think this is a troll this is a troll
thing that happened and we were the butt
of the joke so don't trust this don't
use it until next time
you